ein seiner kollegen und heftet ein blick
an das kleine alltäglich
toilette stadt masterplan fensterrahmen
stadt architektur vision an der
diesjährigen biennale überrascht kurator
rem koolhaas mit der rückkehr zu den
wurzeln der baukunst er zerlegt das
gebäude in seine einzelteile und
versucht das alphabet der architektur
nochmals zu denken
es ist in dem sinn eine fast ohrfeige
und alle bisherigen architekturbiennale
wo man eher ein hehres thema hatte eine
große metaebene
und hier findet man kein einziges
zeitgenössisches architekturprojekt im
elements of architecture es geht wie
gesagt um diese grundfragen des raumes
des alltags das kurhaus zu handfestem
zurückkehrt ist nicht selbstverständlich
denn er zählt zu den theoretikern und
großen dramaturgen der architektur
er denkt von anfang an mehr importen als
in dachrinnen als junger architektur
abgänger katapultiert ihn sein buch deal
ihres new york in den olymp der
architekturgeschichte
er beschreibt darin die stadt als raster
wuchernder wolkenkratzer die das ideal
einer verdichteten lebensform erlaubt
jedes gebäude eine collage von anekdoten
thema filmthema collage montage ist in
diesem jahr enorm wichtig und im
unterschied zu anderen architekten die
schreiben und theoretisieren hat diese
nähe zur alltagskultur zur massenkultur
zum konsum zum kapitalismus sehr viel
provoziert gerade auch in den 70er
jahren haben das in europa weniger
gemacht
kohlhaas geschichte des bauens beginnt
mit der box von mies van der rohe einer
seiner ersten entwürfe die villa darwin
paris dekonstruiert die box und
verbindet zwei unabhängige einheiten
durch einen swimmingpool
30 jahre später ist aus der box eine
aufklappbare schachtel geworden wie in
der bibliothek von zehn wären
verschiedene öffentliche funktionen die
form des baus bestimmen
kohlhaas denkt filmisch denken anfängen
höhepunkten und episoden so ist die
rampe in der casa dem musiker in porto
eine art einstieg in einen film die
treppe baut spannung auf die dann zur
climax führt im konzertsaal mit aussicht
auf die stadt
das ganze ist verpackt in einer
ausgehöhlten box
doch je globaler der architekt umso
größer seine visionen in peking hat
kohlhaas für den staatlichen
chinesischen fernsehsender cctv zwei
wolkenkratzer gebaut die zu einem klub
zusammengeführt sind eine gigantische
stadt in der stadt und eine architektur
die sich nicht mehr und den rest der
stadt kümmern muss ich habe versucht die
aufmerksamkeit der städte zu verschieben
weg von der westlichen situation wenn
man sieht wie und wodurch stellte anders
funktionieren
entdeckt man die schwäche der westlichen
europäischen städte das bewusstsein sie
seien besser ist überheblich und
politisch dumm kohlhaas ist fasziniert
von städten wie dubai die so schnell
wachsen dass sie von null aufgebaut
werden ohne geschichte ohne identität
sein masterplan für die stadt hat
dimensionen der architektur die nur sich
selber genügen müssen
im alten europa hingegen sorgen seine
große entwürfe für kontroversen die sie
sich um das stadtzentrum von den haar
entfacht haben
aber vielleicht schlägt kohlhaas mit
seinen grundlagen der architektur eine
brücke zwischen ost und west in richtung
einer globalen sprache der architektur